Speaker 1: All right, this next clip, I admit to
you. One hundred and ten percent is disaster porn.
Mike Lindell, the CEO of Mike Pillow. The CEO
of MyPillow, who I sometimes referred to as
Mike Pillow, he is back on the Steve
Bannon show on Real America's Voice
War Room. You know, it's a very long
name, and he has a new blockbuster lawsuit
with evidence to get Donald Trump reinstated.
Bannon asks him, When is it going to court?
And Pillow says it's going to court in two weeks.
We're going to do since it's the end of the year,
we're going to take a tour through 2021 with
pillow, all of the different times that he
said. He has all of these blockbuster lawsuits
and things. So this is the new one. He has
another deadline and it's coming up very soon.
Speaker 2: In any, it's like throwing a gun
in a river where you killed someone.
You can't throw away the evidence.
So that's what they've tried to do. But hey, let's
let us go. Let's go. Let's go to commercial break
just ones. The ones is finally going to take
place. I should be by within the next two weeks.
We've got it all ready to go. We've just
got to get it filed in D.C. with the judge.
It's like saying,
Speaker 1: OK, that's that's the new one
in just a couple of weeks. It's going to happen
now. Remember all of the times he said this.
I don't have two hours to play all of the
instances, but let's go through a couple of these.
Remember, back on May 25th, Pillow appeared with
Steve Bannon, and he said he's gathering evidence
and he's got white hat hackers and any any moment
attorneys general. We're going to be on board. And
before you knew it, Trump was going to be back.
Speaker 2: But your air game walk us through the
critical path of the game. Critical. Well,
it started, you know, when I first got the
evidence and that was on January 9th, and as I
got more and more and did my own due diligence,
it had teams of people gathering this. What we
have is we have cyber war called cyber package.
These are forensic packets that you can't
change. There are 100 percent evidence of
each flip that happened to each attack by China.
Speaker 1: These are cyber. These are immutable
cyber packets and presumably not
packets of mustard and ketchup.
Speaker 2: And what I did there is I wanted to
make sure I went out and got the best white hat.
Hackers are different ones from different parts
of the government that are that are protect our
country. They validated everything. So now we have
our royal flush to bring to the Supreme Court.
But what we're doing now we have about, I
believe it's five different cyber teams,
different teams where we're doing so.
Speaker 1: He had elements of cyber
and they were ready to go. That was May
25th. That, of course, didn't happen. Then
he had the August 13th deadline, August 13th
deadline. He missed that one, and he said,
Well, the don't worry, I have a new deadline
Speaker 2: 2020 to 2020. People want change
now. We can't wait. The Twenty
Twenty four for things to reverse.
This country is going down a road right
now that has to be reversed now. Yeah,
it has to happen now. It's broke. Twenty twenty
one hundred percent. Twenty twenty one and it's
out this election when it does get pulled
down. You know, there are so many other
don't take this effect that maybe the Supreme
Court now they just threw a whole new election,
which is fine. But remember everybody, we have to
melt down the machines and make prison bars out of
Speaker 1: exactly melt the machines down now.
He said it would definitely happen in 2021.
It is, of course, December 30th, 2021. We
are down to the last about 30, you know,
thirty something hours left in the year didn't
happen. Then we go to October 22nd, where Mike
Pillow's said he was canvasing for voter fraud
in 20 states, which is of course, weird because
he claimed in May to have all the evidence. Why
are you now canvasing a year after the election?
But that's what he was doing, supposedly
Speaker 2: to tell us about your efforts.
Are we making in your mind? Are we making part
because you're not a guy? Fools yourself, right?
Speaker 1: Well, only in his
mind is progress being made.
That's actually an interesting way to phrase it.
Speaker 2: The built this company out of nothing
to be one of the most important manufacturing
companies. Are you wasting your time or do
you believe you're getting traction as you're
going around? Because I try to we try to talk
every day and I know you're all over the country.
You're right, president presenting with attorney
generals, representing with the secretary of state
in the audience because the audience loves you.
But are you wasting your time? Are you getting
traction on this? No, we're getting traction.
I've I met with five states in three days. That's
why I couldn't come on your show this week. It's
been I've been very busy. I fly out of one state
to another. I haven't been named in the states.
I've told the attorney general to stop. It's all
in confidence till we all sign this together.
Speaker 1: And guys, please Bannon and pilau
both attorney generals, its attorneys general,
they're attorneys. They're not generals, please
Speaker 2: and put this out the second or the
Tuesday before Thanksgiving. Before the Supreme
Speaker 1: Court, so that was that new deadline
Tuesday before Thanksgiving,
and then a little more time went by. And again
again, this was just like a week later. Again,
Bannan says it's that right before Thanksgiving,
it's absolute genius. Of course, it didn't happen.
Speaker 2: What I love about this,
they said, Hey, you just get Trump out,
orange man. Bad to get Biden. You can start. You
can start having holidays again, right? Without
arguing at the table and at each other's throats.
But Mike Lindell comes in and he's going to go to
Wednesday, the eve of Thanksgiving, on a marathon.
So you can go back and have fistfights. The family
squabbles Lindell. You're a genius. Oh,
you could have thought of this, Steve. The
country is going to go back at your holidays are
ruined again. OK? No, no, no, no. I love it. It's
different now. 30 Some percent of Democrats
now believe this country restored and through
the machine. This it's going to do you guys
Speaker 1: think Bannon really believes this stuff
or is he just entertaining it for the clicks?
In any case, Mike Pillow's guarantee of a 2021
reinstatement of Donald Trump is down to its last
30 something hours. It's not going to happen. It's
not going to happen. But there will be a new
deadline, I am sure. And if you're listening
today and you want to see some of these clips,
we'll have them on our Instagram. You can find
us on Instagram at David Pakman show. And we will
take a quick break and be back right after this.